Charles Barkley joining us inside the
NBA studio analyst of Famer Charles how
are you today I'm doing okay how are you
there playing basketball in China this
morning in China and if you were in
stand up
well you can't be killing tournaments
happening for the last X of our years 23
could be oblique please I thought that
what was interesting is we haven't heard
anything from China as far as Adam
silver or anybody else like this is a
good thing you you just want to get
these games over with get out
and then hopefully you can repair things
so what do you think of the job Adams
silver has done so far
which for the owners and counter we're
clear
like I sat down this is billions and
billions of dollars
I'm going to Friday 8:30 summer let's
make this bowl of sand you know why
cause if not billions of dollars it's
easy to survive the biggest and we don't
have in a scan of the game there's an
atom sit and work for the owners and the
players over keepers for the losers then
we're talking billions of dollars
billions of dollars so I totally
understand it it's an awful situation
but this is Charlie this is not the
United States throw these guys out here
with a pleated moral high ground on
these are the same people have been
hating or colored companies on for the
EMP what happens in your dynasties will
happen what happens in China I just
laugh at all these fools I on Williamson
live up to the hype this year and 90mph
successful I was watching the ESPN
pregame show last night and they use the
comparison because we always have to
compare somebody and they used you and
Dominique Wilkins for Zion Williamson a
hybrid of you two
what do you think of that comparison
maybe he's clearly parity as in freedom
official NBA game a nominee to the Hall
of Fame also listen I think I know the
kid a looser noting that the bear but is
this respected as a player that said
he's me
already I mean I'm in the home to see to
compare him to me and I'm these peoples
who agree please a normal thing yeah I I
think that people are going to be a
little bit surprised maybe a little bit
disappointed when they watch Zion in the
numbers that he puts up because I said
if he could put up the numbers that
Julius Randle put up for this team last
year I'd be thrilled if you said he went
21 and 10 I'd be thrilled with that I
think that we think he's going to have
these monster nights and he might but I
just don't think that the end you know
the NBA is different than you know
playing an ACC schedule like he did it
Duke you got some grown men in there and
he's gonna have to be able to shoot the
jumper I love I love he's a good team
player got a great feel for the game
passes the ball well I just don't want
people to go only only averaged 17 and 9
this year I mean I think the best is
ever been I just want to see the kid
play oh be great because I think he'd be
great for the NBA if the rest of the
crazy man I don't know what he's going
to do like I say I got great things in
avid enginee David Griffin but things
like a recant well let's just let this
thing play out I mean I don't think
there's a playoff team by any stretch of
imagination but RAM the West is just
going to be fun to watch and I can't
wait for the Sousa gets thrown in a
couple you think that they should look
into receding when you get to the
playoffs that you don't take out the
east and west
you know that's a great question and
that's a great question listen Milwaukee
apparently I think the walk in Philly
are the best contains in the easier
fashion kind of affair but in the West I
got zero ideas going into West you know
I don't know how you know obviously
abroad at 80 they got to be fantastic
I don't know what can I was going to do
it load management and I'll come back
you know building and you talk to really
think you got Portland these back to the
rocket that's gonna be fascinating to
watch employment will see Western
Hemisphere is going to be 15 I think a
long time and I cannot wait for the NBA
to start just man listen Greece out
there there's some really great stories
in the West I can't wait to see them the
spark what's your biggest concern with
the Lakers Anthony babies on the bronze
health you know the boss older boy like
you don't get those eat he used to get
three or four easy games a year will get
that in the West
you saw last year if he missed any time
you're not gonna make the twelve and
after the baby just got to prove he can
stay healthy
those are my two biggest concerns are
with the Lakers LeBron's head and
eighties well aware you know he lose -
only two games last year he came honest
in the West he missed 22 games in the
West the Cooper I'm not insured
everything's talking to Charles Barkley
inside the NBA tnt studio analyst can
you explain this beef between Shaq and
Damian Lillard
[Music]
[Music]
you know it was good TV though when you
said you wanted a punch trim dream on
the face anything we don't get to say
everything we want to on television like
I work for a network and you know we we
took the same one able be renting but we
can say talk through some things but you
don't get that [ __ ] anymore you don't
get the superhero team we got a business
dealing with China and any other connect
Airtel occasion which I'm here they
solve our own problems in America and we
want us to hold about hospice and Carlos
really least efficient but we don't do
pursue
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is there a basketball chord for me yeah
I don't care about tennis but basketball
I'll steal your money a shooting contest
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay I'm gonna the dance and I are gonna
huddle as we you know we we take a
commercial break here and we'll figure
out when we can come out there and see
all right I don't like people all right
all right is how big is the big house by
the way all right
hey great to talk to you as always and
thank you but that's Charles Barkley all
of Famer TNT inside the NBA studio
analyst I don't know can you guys get a
Hall Pass from your wife yes okay I just
talked to you just want to make sure
everybody community go out there yeah I
do not want to show this on TV so don't
shoot it I've got a picture of Charles
Barkley's house the compound mmm it
looks like if you gave someone a whole
bunch of money's had built a playground
which basically what they did with
Charles okay it's got putting chipping
pools plural yes yes Richard before I
could hang up with him after he wrapped
up with you he's insisting that we do a
week of shows he's like he doesn't want
to take no for an answer he's totally
ready to roll out the red carpet have us
do shows yeah but he does TNT so when
can we go out there when he's gonna be
there when he's not covering the NBA
that's what we got to figure out but
we've got to do that that's the they do
show some Charles Barkley's backyard how
awesome would that be it'd be nice to do
two shows there like we do sort of a
Pebble Beach show and we do a dry run
for our Pebble Beach shows and then we
do it in his backyard for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR Live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]